[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zur rallye
fällt heute packe ich mini cupcakes und
zwar habe ich die schon auf der messe in
freiburg zubereitet und den zuschauern
haben die super geschmeckt im prinzip
ist es einfach eine abwandlung vom
normalen faktoren den kenn ja viele als
blechkuchen da hat man einfach fand mit
dem rührteig und dann wird das ganze im
blech gebacken mit einer creme versehen
und man drehen oder 40 stücke mit rein
und ich habe das ganze als mini cup
cakes zubereitet vor allem finde ich
diese süßen kleinen cupcakes toll denn
man kann sie einfach aus der hand heraus
essen
man braucht nicht viel geschehen man
braucht kein teller können gesteckt und
diesen hat wirklich zuckersüß aus und
ich zeige euch jetzt wie man sie
zubereitet und hier vorne stehen auch
schon die zutaten für den rührteig für
die panther-fans brauche ich 150 eine
prise salz 220 gramm mehl einen halben
teelöffel backpulver und vier teelöffel
natron zweier etwas manila extrakt 150
milliliter sonnenblumenöl und 100
milliliter fand ich nehme jetzt zuerst
einmal die trockenen zutaten und
fernsehen der schüssel also zucker salz
das mehl und backpulver und nato
falls ihr kein natrium hut nehmen die
einfach nur backpulver aber mit natron
gehen die muffins einfach ein bisschen
besser aus dann kurz verrühren und jetzt
kommen hier noch die flüssigen zutaten
rein also die eier etwas dran den
extrakt das öl und fanta und wenn jetzt
kein fanta da habt könnt ihr auch
einfach mineralwasser und jetzt werden
die zutaten einfach kurz berührt
[Musik]
damit ich den teig einfacher
funktionieren kann fühle ich ihn jetzt
in einen spritzbeutel ihr könnt aber zum
beispiel auch einen gefrierbeutel nehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die spritztour schließlich einfach mit
einem gummiband
so kann nichts mehr auslaufen und
schneidet hier vorne eine ganz kleine
spitze weg und jetzt habe ich hier
zweimal auf den backförmchen des minimal
fans mit papier förmchen ausgekleidet
ihr könnt natürlich auch ganz normale
großem aufwand machen
aber die kleine finde ich wirklich super
süß die kann man einfach aus der hand
essen und die förmchen werden jetzt zu
drei vierteln mit dem teig befüllt
[Musik]
jetzt kann man die muffins in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze und da brauchen sie etwa
zwölf bis vierzehn minuten die muffins
gebacken und werden sie komplett
abkühlen lassen
jetzt habe ich hier noch als topping für
das topping nehme ich jetzt schwand und
sahne sind eine richtig leckere creme
und ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für
die füllung brauche ich 200 gramm
schmandt 200 gramm sahne etwas vanille
extrakt 20 gramm puderzucker fünf
teelöffel seiner tat und zum bestreuen
etwas sinnvoll war und zum belegen
mandarinen aus der dose
zuerst aber bereit sich dem spritzbeutel
vor
da kommt eine kleine tür rein das ist
jetzt so eine stern thüle
das kann es schon mal hier in den
schriftsteller stellen und dann gibt
genau dann geht's weiter mit der sahne
creme lassen wir mal hin
jetzt kommt die sahne in einen hohen
rohr besser
die dame mit scheiß geschlagen und da
geht es währenddessen seiner partner von
polycom und sucht man elektra
[Musik]
ja
ohne bei mir leicht gemacht
die sache ist jetzt halb steif da gebe
ich jetzt noch den station und ein
bisschen puderzucker da noch das
restliche sommerbad und jetzt kann die
creme komplett steif geschlagen werden
[Musik]
die creme finde ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel 1
und jetzt spritzig kleine tupfen auf die
muffins
[Musik]
jetzt besteht die mavs noch mit etwas
zimt und damit nicht zu viel sind aus
dem haus kommt habe ich hier einfach ein
bischen reis drin
das ist so ein kleiner tipp und dann
einfach so ein bisschen drüber streuen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt setzt sich einfach auf jeden
marvin eine mandarine
nein zumindest eine wanderung spalte
[Musik]
wir sehen jetzt die fertigen cupcakes
aus uns ist wirklich hübsch
ich denke für den kindergeburtstag ja
für nachmittag kaffee klatsch wir haben
jetzt mehr als lehrerzimmer also weniger
personen sind durch etwas größeres
machen aber ich finde es auch schön weil
das versteck und nun auch noch züge
im letzte mal hatten wir halt immer
hatte ja immer was mit gebrochenen immer
wieder morgens zur arbeit gegangen ist
als lehrerin
hast du mal was gebacken und zu arbeiten
ja ich finde es lustig und habe immer
gedacht hey geht direkt zur arbeit oder
geht die zugucken essen kaffee gehabt
bei mir geht es immer um leben und tod
also es ist wichtig dass man einfach bis
zu überlegen erstmal sanierer ist so
wundervoll aus
[Musik]
so ist aus richtig schön hat jetzt auf
jeden fall empfehlen gekocht und
geschmeckt ja ich hoffe schon dass sich
das schon gesagt ja also ziemlich
obendrauf fordern jedoch vor allem sehr
einfach und die zuschauer auf der messe
die von uns sehr auch richtig lecker
waren erst noch ein bisschen ja ich hab
doch ich hatte nur einen spritzbeutel
also meine schule nicht dabei so
ja da wahnsinnig ganz so schön aber
jetzt ist schluss mit spritztour ja und
falls ihr das rezept gerne nachmachen
möchte dann schaut auf meinem blog
vorbei aufs alice lock data steht noch
mal alles ganz genau und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß nachbacken dir noch
viel spaß beim dekorieren die nämlich
gleich mit seiner freundin stella sehr
schön es hat auch schon brief dafür
geschrieben weil ich selber ja dann
schreibe ich noch mal okay okay also bis
zum nächsten mal ein bisschen exotisch
hier beispielsweise erinnert habe
das erste video dabei war schnell eine
schoko vor dem 8 damals hatte ich auch
nicht alle szene weiß dass ich auch
gerade die nachgewachsenen darstellte
waren damals die milchzähne jetzt ins
all die ja und jetzt kommen 17 die
zahlen lägen weit weg sagt man macht's
gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]